[Music]
have you guys been grocery shopping
recently oh yeah about once a week I go
like once every month now yeah I go we
like to save you so much money we go go
on seven three weeks I sue every day
every day yeah not anymore but I feel
like cuz so my mom could go shoe
shopping once and we'll have food for a
year right you know I'm scraping
everything for me it's like I go for one
specific dish what's that this is done
it's done no I'll go every single day
just to get the freshest thing and then
also the logic was I don't want to waste
food if I go get like a week's worth I
might not get through everything in that
week don't you guys plan it out yeah the
next day I don't know what I'm cooking
the next year sometimes like like shoot
schedules or whatever like you know you
just don't get time to actually cooking
it and then eventually back then though
for some reason I didn't we didn't
really have the greatest fridge either
in terms of like storage space and
freezers so we didn't really have
anywhere to put the meats in or the
vegetables but now we got the new fridge
and now we're forced to like really plan
everything out but I'm ready I'm ready
to [ __ ] like change my mind you go to
the grocery store with like a recipe and
mine always really I do the opposite now
now I'm just like meat get it who knows
when we'll know we might not ever see
this again
it was amazing they actually say that
it's safer to go the beach than it is to
go to the grocery store open air because
there's open air the ventilation cluster
and contact will way more people
touching the same a lot of things at the
beach it's like obviously they're like
just because it's a what do they call it
like not a necessity it's for fun it's
like a pleasure thing it's like what
we're trying to cut back on those things
I'm also not close to that many
strangers when I'm at the beach like I
got a good amount of distance between me
and anyone I don't know and it's kind of
hard to share sand when you guys are at
the grocery store do you guys really
intentionally like obey the six-feet
rule hell yeah yeah especially walk by
do you do you like do whoa
only when I hang because I have the
markers where I go
if you're gonna go down the aisle I'm
gonna almost you have so many different
signs and stuff they have those I made
the biggest fuck-up because I only go
once every like two three weeks now so
every time I go I think new rules yeah
so I went in and you can only enter
through one side of the grocery store
now and every aisle you it's a one-way
aisle have you seen that no so how does
someone like seeing it pass them so like
let's say you want to go on I of 17
right but the arrow is pointing the
opposite direction you have to go down
the opposite Wow
so I went in I went in not knowing this
and because I was just talking to my
girlfriend in time we're just walking in
like normal and I didn't pay attention
to the sign that was in fun to me that
says hey don't go in this one going
against traffic yes I win against
traffic you're an Asian driver even a
grocery store the worker just like gave
me like the worst air I was gonna be
like oh hello how are you doing but he
gave me the worst there that made me mad
excuse me was like oh by the way you
have to go on the other side but he
would just give me this light and then
you just walk away like they say you
came and have more than like two or
three people in a certain aisle or
whatever so you kind of have to wait
yeah yeah because that most recent time
Isaac and I went to the grocery store
and I that's when I first noticed the
one-way stickers but by the time I
noticed I was already going the opposite
way luckily no one else is in the aisle
but I was like oh my gosh there's new
world now you almost caught the virus
going that way almost you do you feel
like a badess you're like I got it I'll
but I gotta go in the opposite direction
ho what am I doing here and I'm feeling
really silly
like when I'm grocery shopping I just
feel really weird that like I'm trying
to do my thing
but then there's like certain people in
the aisle where I'm like well [ __ ] I
don't want to invade their space thing
but I'm like well [ __ ] it is just two
seconds like let me just pick you hold
your breath oh let me just go really
quickly
it's weird some people are extra
paranoid too so I when I was there I
felt like I had to rush out of an Iowa
because it was so I was in an aisle like
looking at whatever it was I needed to
get right and I could see the person
behind me finish grabbing what they
needed but they were too scared to pass
me so they were standing there for an
extra couple minutes of me staring at
the thing and I was like I just feel bad
so I left the aisle so they could leave
and I went back into the aisle people on
the same page I was grabbing the
shopping cart and this lady comes in
behind me and then she has like the mask
dangling from her ear like this and she
goes don't have to pull my mask and
they're like yes Oh
oh my god and then when I by the way uh
but after she went in and she started
shopping like she just moved it down the
show just wearing it like this people
are on different pages people are like
six feet and then there's people that
are just like straight up don't give a
[ __ ] and then there's people like this
guy who in San Diego decided to wear his
KKK hoodie a joke it's a cloth mask
it seemed serious enough is it a 95
hoodie though no it's not and it's in
San Diego San Diego in the city called
San T so this grocery cellphone know
he's getting the paper bag how did they
get it so pointy on the top maybe they
just buy those birthday party houses
yeah and actually I don't know it's just
my eyes but it looks like you could see
through it and there's like something
holding it imagine if they have like a
like a ring like this and then a [ __ ]
spike like those dresses right or am i
tripping well if you if you get the
officially KKK license stuff it's very
pointy if you get that but it looks like
a selfie stick or something and the
funny thing is it's it's so thin the
cloth is so so thin it's it seems to be
bad oh maybe he's not one of the top
guys he's like a recruit he needs a 10-9
version of 95 90 and 95 yeah so then um
hard to see in there I know right Django
see we just thought chicken goat see we
all did yeah I always wondered can they
turn their heads in it would it like
mess it up
right so hold it here I want to meet one
so bad I want to be like hey sir do you
hate me more and you're playing a black
guy or do you hate that guy more like is
their levels of like who do you hate
that guy up in a Mexican guy or me one
of us out of the country who would it be
they should do a you know Jubilee
project has like Republicans versus
whatever right they should do one where
they bring a KKK guy on and we can ask
him questions I bet as Asians we
probably jumped up a couple notches
there now because of the kronos right so
before they didn't care about it yeah we
were probably the safest yeah and now
we're like waking up we're ranking up
yeah before we were probably right there
with Mexicans but now they probably want
us like out first and foremost they
hated Mexicans you guys probably yeah we
we were on the lowest I don't know but
there's no we're the top of the class
not you know yeah well I think sometimes
we're just non-existent in America so
when they look at they're like wait why
should I give you attention you're not
even here
I just want at least care then we had
the title I'd already so yeah so this
happened at bond no and okay so
apparently there was someone who took
this photo and then tweeted out I'm
surprised no one [ __ ] his ass off well
so they end up shooting out don't know
which angers me more the person wearing
this or the fact that no one in
management at Vons Santee did anything
about it because they're scared they
made a mother approached a guy okay Kim
s not just KKK but like imagine if a
dude had a like a [ __ ] outfit from top
to bottom blue from head to toe like I
mean I'd be like [ __ ] I don't know if I
want to step up to this violence
dangerous what a guy
a swastika like [ __ ] for his bad data
like it's people are scared what the
[ __ ] are they gonna say well eventually
the management did approach the man to
the point where they said you either
need a remover hood or you have to leave
so he decided to remove the hood so
there are apparently photos out there
this man without the hood
mind if I get him in trouble think the
policeman self you could have just used
the hood as a facemask why did he have
to put the whole thing on what does he
have in a shopping cart
what if y'all like fried chicken
watermelon why it's like hella
Asian [ __ ] I wonder what the boundary is
like how how white do they have to be
like it has to be only bratwurst yeah
you know only hamburgers or hotdogs all
American food yeah you know how vegans
are like so hardcore vegan they only
like even their clothes have to be vegan
yeah like how like how many pieces of
their clothing is made in America
everything has to be probably like
orange chicken
I know right what are the boundaries
like you know literally everything is
made in China yeah shopping cart
honestly what he hates
it's just weight trying to get apples in
this photo yeah but you know even a lot
of the produce is it from America do
American bombs exist
what kind of phone is he use oh yeah he
probably anything does it [ __ ] uses
Morse code Japanese Marvel he lives in a
container that he outfitted under the
ground and he's using Morse code crazy
that'll piss like that like you would
think like San Diego and OC they're like
more racist and Republican there's a lot
of them yeah they're I think at this
point I'm just waiting for a YouTube
video to come out to say that it was all
social experiment I know right not sure
these days you can never be too sure
there is uh I think there's like a
headquarters for the KKK in the Orange
County area in Irvine there's like
there's like a cliffside private air
how is that like how are they still
around like how is it not illegal it do
not car washes and stuff so that you
please my I'm like legally like isn't it
like because they don't consider
themselves in a hate group like we're
just a club yeah it's a club yeah I mean
they I don't think they're doing like
what like cleanse and like mean sons and
Iraqis like you know really like this
isn't a man with some cinematic rights
like big feet they're doing the gun
trade and drug trade on stuff I feel
like a lot of these guys I think it's
all on the internet they're reading [ __ ]
they're like yeah bro whatever and then
then they have their own little stuff to
do at home
I don't think theirs was driven here in
California I thought they were all gonna
den down down down down down that's why
that's why I'm just like what okay
California I would see like how long
does they know that apply America
American History X kind of [ __ ] what
would you do if you saw that as a ghost
sorry I feel like I'd probably just grab
his head and run O'Reilly would use son
I got questions I need what if you get
corona from his [ __ ] face Oh like I
don't think that the KKK scares me maybe
because I feel like the invisible race
like I'm not their target or I don't
feel like I'm the target even though
they are a sign of hate so if I see it
I'm just like what the [ __ ] especially
in California if I saw that [ __ ] like in
Georgia I would have been like oh how
stereotypical true but yeah that would
kind of shocked me I'll be like what the
[ __ ] am I seeing what I'm seeing right
now and probably go up to a minute I ask
them
so do you buy all USA products or what's
up dude I think it's possible
[Music]